with Stannis only able to beat Hulk  because he had the power stone or is he  just that horrible I would I would say  that he's just that powerful I mean he  didn't he didn't see him actively use  the power stone in the fight I think  ultimately the way we looked at that  fight in the way he talked about it with  our stunt team when we were executing  was Hulk is obviously very powerful but  he's a little mindless in his fighting  style its aggressive pummeling fanouts  is the Genghis Khan of the universe he's  a very skilled fighter equally as strong  so when you put those two up against  each other the more skilled fighter is  going to win ultimately which is why  Hulk has a moment where he overpowers  Thanos but ultimately Thanos is smarter